Bissell's Big Green
deep cleaning machine
is quick and easy to use.
Start by vacuuming
the entire area.
Remove the dirty water
tank from the top
and lift the clean water tank
from the base of the machine.
Take the clean water
tank to your sink.
Now fill with hot tap
water to the water line
that's indicated on the tank.
Add two capsules of
Bissell's solution.
You've got plenty
of solution choices
to fit your cleaning needs.
Next, replace the tanks,
making sure the dirty water
tank is properly seated on
top of a clean water tank.
And you're ready to clean.
Start the machine and
recline the handle.
Press the trigger and
make one slow forward
and backward pass over the area.
Release the trigger and make one
slow forward and backward pass
over the same area to suction
up additional dirty water
from the carpet.
Avoid oversaturating the area.
The flow indicator
on the machine
stops spinning to
let you know when you
need more water and solution.
Empty the dirty water
tank into the sink
and refill the clean water
tank with additional water
and solution as necessary.
When you are completely
finished cleaning,
make sure to empty and rinse
both the clean and dirty water
tanks and return back
onto the machine.
Check the brush roll and
the bottom of the machine
for dirt and debris.
Quick, easy, and you're done.
Bissell's Big Green
deep cleaning machine.